rutherford b hayes this is an outlier in
american history
because the electoral college gave
most of its votes to rutherford hayes
opponent
new york governor sam tilden who is a
democrat running against ohio governor
rutherford b hayes the republican tilden
beat hayes on the popular vote after the
first
round of of electoral votes tilden had
184 electoral votes to hayes's
165 electoral votes
there were 20 electoral votes from about
four states does this sound familiar
there were three in particular that were
really at play florida
louisiana and south carolina okay then
there was also the question of
oregon this fourth state where one
elector was replaced
after being declared illegal for being
an elected or appointed official
so you've got these four outstanding
states what are we going to do
sounds very very familiar the way they
resolve this
is that the constitution provides quote
the president of the senate shall
in presence of the senate and house of
representatives open all the electoral
certificates
and the votes shall then be counted
so you have the electors go right you go
to vote and then
the states pick a slate of electors the
electors go and they vote in the
electoral college that's still not quite
the end of it to declare the
president-elect
because then the president of the senate
opens the votes and the president
presence of the senate and the house of
representatives they count the votes and
then you've got the president-elect
now this is a tricky phrase in the
constitution during this crisis of 1876
the republicans interpreted this
provision of the constitution to mean
that the power to count the votes lay
with the president
of the senate and the house and the
senate were just there kind of to watch
but the president of the senate had the
power to count the votes
but because the president of the senate
was republican then
hayes would win democrats interpreted
this differently they said that they
need to
need to follow the practice that had
been followed since 1865.
which says that no vote that was
objected to
by anybody should be counted except by a
concurrence of
both houses of congress the congress and
the senate
now because of this because the the
congress had
the house of representatives rather had
a democrat majority that would have
thrown the election
to tilden so what are we to do the even
the constitution here is a little
unclear
well what happened is the congress
passed a law on january 29
1877 that formed a 15-member electoral
commission that would then determine
this presidential election
five members of the house five members
of the senate five members of the
supreme court
the effect of this is what's called the
compromise
of 1877 which gave the election
to rutherford b hayes sometimes called
rutherfraud
hayes how do you like that lame
political nicknames were popular even
in the 19th century hayes gets the
presidency
however hayes has to promise to pull
the federal troops out of the south and
end
reconstruction which hayes does this has
sort of calamitous effects
for everybody but that's how that
election panned out
are we going to see something like that
here i'm i'm not being flippant about it
we have a hotly contested presidential
election
there is evidence of fraud systemic
fraud actually some just came out within
the last couple of days
uh we we haven't had an election that's
hotly contested
possibly since since 1876.
uh so is this going to happen are we
going to get the compromise of 2021 i
don't think so
because even if you were to follow the
example
of the electoral commission let's say
you got five members of the senate and
senate's held by republicans so let's
say that that goes for
trump and then you got five members of
the house
and house is controlled by democrats
that goes for biden then you got five
members of the supreme court the supreme
court's already ruled in they don't want
to
overturn the perception that joe biden
won the election
so presumably even on some kind of
commission electoral commission
that would still go to biden so i'm not
not particularly hopeful but it is
at least worthwhile to point out to
people who say it's completely all over
now
technically it's actually not totally
all over now but it certainly looks
as though it is i think that's why
president trump is trying to fit in so
much uh into this last few moments here
certainly on the vaccine we talked about
the vaccine for the virus
but even various uh actions that he can
take
to change the bureaucracy actions to set
up various special counsel
uh ways to speed up executions in the
criminal justice system
he's doing a lot of things now on the
assumption that he will not be the
president by the end of january
[Music]
[Music]
you